non ho niente da guardare per halloween
che poi potrei anche parlare solo di
qualche figlio in particolare ci sono un
sacco di film che la gente non ha mai
visto sono sconosciuti le strane
creature dello spazio le collane dvd
explora 6
e questi sono dei testicoli nella
stratosfera sembra molto interessante
non ho idea di come sia finito nemi dvd
per dei paranormal entity quadrilogia
attenzione contiene immagini violente e
disturbante ipol fatto che sia la copia
di paranormal activity ma fatta dalla
sail un decidi la verità per te stesso
non so cosa cazzo vuol dire poi la notte
dei morti viventi 3 di occhiali 3d
inclusi che sia quello che sento
sbriciolato dentro la custodia a miseria
per meno gli occhialini ci sono per
davvero
qui come sottotitolo ci stava un bel
perché il vero e proprio paranormal
activity il film che ha terrorizzato
l'america
siete delle pur se questo in particolare
il terzo ma per quanto non mi faccia
particolarmente spaventare io adoro la
storia dei parà romantici la lord e in
paranormal activity è tanto per restare
in tema paranormal experience
experimenta il terrore
giusto giusto ci hanno lucrato un
pochino sopra volo roma activity oh mio
dio questo è troppo
questo è troppo hulk hogan oltre in
champ dalle immagini sembra una merda o
acciuga radu brado le avventure per al
che i suoi amici sono appena cominciate
ma non temete grandi khanjani è solo
routing per hulk hogan il campione
assoluto
sono contentissimo ho questo è uno
veramente bello fronti e ai confini
dell'inferno farà molto male e se lo
dice la custodia il chino e ci credi
non capisco perché la gente non vada a
vedere i film horror francesi che sono
fantastici
questo più che una merda è stata una
delusione chernobyl diaries
sarà perché l'ha fatto il creatore di
paranormal activity fra tutte la forma
di radiazione che però sembra anche un
teschio
poi se vuoi farti quattro risate shaolin
contro i mostri diabolici
voglio dire al cinema è passato di
peggio perché no e comunque ci gordon
liu che anche un bravo attore pagato ben
un euro e cinquanta una miscela di arti
marziali e orrore per un film pieno di
effetti speciali
ecco speciali è la parola giusta o
wrestler versus zombies
oh scusate pro all star wrestler versus
zombie game boy ben più ad altro per chi
adora wrestling questo è oro cia rodino
di piper me tardi scendo glass kurt
angle gindac questo sembra fighissimo
però mi serve un costume speciale per
guardarlo
misteri
roma beh manca la parrucca coi capelli
lunghi 200 kg proprio per il resto ci
siano telecomando
madre de dios
e meglio di qualsiasi ora questa cosa
qui voi non avete idea si è fatta una
certa età vorrebbe star magazine il
primo numero della rivista sul web star
apparentemente o chissà cosa ci regalerà
gamer non stop tra l'altro no stop
importantissime informazioni sui gamer
nostrani tra i quali gli attrezzi del
mestiere e il suo joystick preferito
porca [ __ ] meno male che me l'hanno
detto ci hanno proprio il magone qua di
saperlo beauty 2.0 sexy skeleton make up
eh sì perché non c'è niente di più sexy
di uno scheletro in cucina con lo chef
gli anni chissà cosa mangiamo oggi
orecchiette con le cime del va bene un
c'è anche al posto del cuore
ciao sono sofia mi piace un ragazzo da
due anni e io piaccio a lui ma il
problema è che non ci parliamo
e come cazzo fai la fate a sapere che vi
piacete a vicenda senza sv mai parlati
io ho saltato una generazione qui
apparentemente si parlano con i genitali
io ti faccio vedere il mio cazzo se tu
mi fai vedere la tua figlia vuol dire
che siamo fidanzati ma non ci siamo mai
parlati è molto bella questa cosa qui il
racconto dei raduni i raduni sono
occasioni uniche che permettono ai
creator di incontrare i propri amici nel
web
intanto amici del web vediamo chi cazzo
mi conosce per il tutto poi vediamo se
amici ne parlerò con l'avvocato che poi
scritta così incontrare i propri amici
del web sembra appunto che voi siate dei
cani ammaestrati
le app da non perdere su sap scherzi
telefonici un'applicazione che vi farà
morire dal ridere
l'unica in grado di fare scherzi
telefonici di tutto rispetto a non solo
[ __ ] agli altri con gli scherzi
telefonici ma non so manco tuoi ma che
comunque se vi va di fare scherzi
telefonici lo potete fare
e poi potrete diventare giurati di
italia's got talent
no dai un saluto a crozza poi ha
immortalato una web star
inviaci la foto gli scatti migliori
realizzati in un buco pubblico verranno
selezionati per il magazine
hai capito se per caso ti sei ritrovato
per errore allora per i [ __ ] a
qualcuno fotografandolo di nascosto
invece la foto al magazine senza su
permesso eh sì perché non puoi diventare
una vestale senza un po di gossip
paparazzo sono contento che abbiano
sottolineato realizzati in un luogo
pubblico perché già immaginavo gente che
scavalcava cancelli per fotografare il
web star mentre cagavano tipo e si
finisce con la categoria video virale
non lo so bene ragazzi spero che video
di halloween vi sia piaciuto io vado ad
ingozzarsi di medicinali modo da morire
serenamente
grazie mille a nice day